In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon from A fifth, on which we commemorate our Holy Father,
Hilary, Bishop of Arles.
The descendant of a wealthy family from Burgundy of Greek origin, St. Hilary was, on completing
his studies, appointed to an important position in the Imperial Administration, entranced by
the world, and its illusory attractions, he remained unreceptive to the exhortations of
his kinsmen, St. Onoratus, who had gone from Lorenz in order to attempt to detach him
from it.
Returning to his monastery, Onoratus prayed for him, and, of a sudden, the brilliant magistrate's
heart was changed.
He rejected all that had been attractive to him until then, gave away all his goods,
and irresistibly drawn by the love of God, with Drew to Lorenz, where he strove with all
of his strength to regain the time lost in futility, and move towards monastic perfection under
St. Onoratus' direction.
When the latter was made archbishop of Arles in 426, Hilary found him to help him in his pastoral
tasks, but, carried away by the love of solitude, he quickly returned to the monastic island
and, however, he responded to Onoratus' request to help him in his last moments.
After the death of the Holy Bishop, Hilary immediately set off back to the monastery
from fear of being elected to succeed him, but he was stopped by Castus, the governor,
and taken back to the town by force, where the clergy and the people proceeded to his election
with a great upsurge of enthusiasm.
When the saint protested, saying that he would only submit if God made it clear that such
was his will, a snow-white dove came and settled on his head, and only flew off when he had
given his consent.
Aged only 29, the new bishop showed the wisdom of an old man, and a fatherly tenderness to
all, especially to the poor.
He worked with his own hands to help them, and sold everything, even the sacred vessels,
to buy back the captives, who had fallen into the hands of German tribes when they invaded
Gal.
His pastoral activities did not, however, make him temper his monastic esquices in any way.
The first act of his episcopate had been to call the clergy together in his cathedral to
have them live together in community as an monastery.
As for him, he remained as poor as before, being clad at all times in a single tunic under
which he hid a hair shirt, going barefoot even in winter, sleeping on the hard ground, working
with his hands while reciting the Psalms, and keeping his spirit unceasingly in the presence
of God.
The current Hillary, shown, especially by his talent for oratory, which was confirmed
by many miracles, he knew how to address himself to the great of this world and to the ordinary
people, and preached the truth of the gospel without prevarication or fear of the powerful,
not hesitating to prove them directly in public.
He showed, however, great tenderness towards sinners, and with his own tears brought penitence
to weep.
His great principle was to lay everything before God, and to watch over the state of his soul
at all times, as though it were about to be examined by the judge of all.
He knew how to transmit this state of spiritual vigilance to his hearers, and no one could
hear or even see him without having his or her heart broken with compunction.
After his sermons, there were many who terrified by the perspective of the judgment, and despising
their present way of life, decided thanksforth to live only for heaven.
Throughout the whole of his Episcopal ministry, St. Hillary fought against heresy, especially
that of Pelagianism, together with his friend St. Germano's of Auxerre.
He presided at a number of councils, re-established ecclesiastical discipline, founded churches,
and monasteries that followed the tradition of Lorenz, and had peace and love reigned
throughout the south of Gaul.
Burnt out by his zeal and austerities, he fell ill at the age of forty-eight, and, after
having designated his successor, gave his soul into God's hands on the 5th of May in 449.
We are told that, during his funeral, the Psalms were sung only in Hebrew by the Jews
of Arles, who also wanted to honor the saint, because the voices of the Christians were choked
by grief.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and
save us.